El 8 de noviembre de 2016,
Donald Trump ganó las elecciones
presidenciales de Estados Unidos contra
todo pronóstico. No vamos a intentar
aparentar que somos imparciales
si queréis podéis pinchar en nuestra
playlist dedicada a las elecciones
americanas de 2016 para ver cuál es
nuestra opinión sobre Donald Trump y
cuál era el candidato al que nosotros
apoyábamos. Sin embargo, y aunque nos
duela,
tenemos que reconocer que la campaña de
Donald Trump ha sido brillante. Y la
prueba es que ha ganado. Por supuesto si
habéis seguido las elecciones desde
medios de comunicación europeos o
latinoamericanos, habréis recibido una
imagen totalmente distinta a la que han
tenido los ciudadanos estadounidenses,
que en última instancia son los que
tienen que votar.
Y precisamente por eso muchos os
estaréis preguntando, ¿cómo es posible
que Donald Trump haya ganado las
elecciones?
Hoy os lo vamos a explicar.
Muchos califican
a Donald Trump como simplemente un
conservador muy radical. Alguien que ha
tomado los principios del Partido
Republicano y los ha llevado al extremo
nada más lejos de la realidad. lo cierto
es que el presidente electo se ha creado
su propia ideología y esto no lo digo
yo lo reconoce él mismo:
"como dije al principio, esto no
ha sido una campaña sino un movimiento
político". Y os preguntaréis cómo se
puede crear una ideología desde cero.
Pues bien existe toda una teoría
política para ello. Lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es encontrar distintas
causas políticas que no están
representadas por ningún partido.
Por ejemplo, los votantes cristianos
evangélicos ya están representados por
los políticos tradicionales del partido
republicano.
Así que no nos valen
Sin embargo, existe toda una clase obrera
blanca que trabaja en el sector de la
automoción, en ciudades industriales como
Detroit que perdió su trabajo durante
la crisis financiera de 2008.
Muchas fábricas cerraron la producción
y la trasladaron a China así que es
normal que este grupo culpe a los chinos
de su mala situación.
Por otro lado tenemos a ese grupo de
votantes resentido con los inmigrantes
mexicanos que han sido capaces de salir
adelante e incluso en muchos casos
montar sus propias empresas y terminar
ganando más dinero que los votantes
blancos tradicionales. Todos estos
sectores existían pero estaban
totalmente huérfanos de representación
política, bien porque se pensaba que
eran demasiado radicales y que
espantarían a otros votantes o bien
simplemente porque se creía que eran
grupos muy reducidos.
Por ejemplo en Estados Unidos nadie se
atreve a pronunciar esa palabra aquí
empieza por "n" y que solamente pueden
decir los raperos... Sin embargo nadie
tiene ningún problema en minusvalorar a
los paletos los "rednecks" y los "hillbillies"
y que son en esencia blancos de clase
media baja. Y esta corrección política
también ha irritado a muchos votantes.
Sin embargo, quién iba a pensar que una
cosa tan estúpida como una simple
palabra pudiera ser determinante para
que mucha gente se decantara por un
candidato.
Pues bien Donald Trump cogió todas esas
causas y las aglutinó en lo que en
teoría política se conoce como un
significante vacío. Y os preguntaréis,
¿qué es un significante vacío? Pues es
una palabra tan genérica que puede
significar lo que cada uno quiera.
Por ejemplo el eslogan de Donald Trump,
hacer que "América vuelva a ser grande
otra vez" puede significar lo que cada
uno quiera.
Para algunos la "América grande"
significa una América libre de
inmigrantes, para otros es un América
que no comercia con China. Es decir, es
una expresión tan bonita como vacía, y por eso a cada uno la llena con el
significado que le interesa.
¿Pero esto realmente funciona? ¿La gente no
se da cuenta de que Donald Trump le está
diciendo a cada uno lo que quiere oír?
Pues bien un elemento imprescindible
para crear un movimiento político es
elegir a un antagonista. Los que seguís
este canal desde hace tiempo
me lo habréis oído decir mil veces. Uno
se define por su apuesto en el caso de
Trump,
tenemos a un enemigo interno que serían
los inmigrantes mexicanos y el
establishment político representado por
Hillary Clinton. Pero también existiría
un enemigo externo que sería China y el
terrorismo islámico.
Gracias al antagonista, Trump nos crea
una identidad. Sus votantes se sienten
parte de algo y por eso justifican
cualquier declaración o cualquier
impertinencia que haya soltado al
candidato durante la campaña.
Pero esperad un momento porque
hay algo más:
el broche de oro de la campaña de
Trump ha sido esa propuesta estrella de
la que hemos hablado todos: el muro en la
frontera entre Estados Unidos y México.
Por supuesto, se trata de algo tan estúpido como irrealizable. Pero desde
el punto de vista del marketing
político es una auténtica obra maestra.
Algo similar a la conquista de la luna
que propuso que Kennedy en los años
60 para conquistar el corazón de sus
votantes. ¿Y por qué es una propuesta tan
poderosa?
Primero porque es algo tangible: frente a
cualquier propuesta fiscal que es un
concepto abstracto,
el muro es algo que podemos visualizar.
Todos nos podemos imaginar un muro.
Además se presenta como una solución
muy sencilla para un problema muy
concreto que la gente cree que existe. Lo tercero es que es un
proyecto lo suficientemente grande como
para ilusionar a los votantes si se
construyera se trataría de una de las
mayores obras de ingeniería de la
historia y eso es ilusionante de por sí.
Gracias a todos estos elementos Donald Trump ha sido capaz de cristalizar una
ideología a la que se le ha llamado
derecha alternativa y que de hecho tiene
su propio medio de comunicación de
referencia que es este portal que veis
aquí que se llama "Breitbart".
Este periódico online se ha
convertido en el órgano de difusión de
la campaña de Trump y en menos de dos
años ha logrado construir una audiencia
superior a la del Huffington Post o el
New York Times, y como veis es un
auténtico panfleto no tenéis más que
ver su portada el día de las elecciones.
Vamos, que sólo les faltó decir hemos
ganado. Breitbart es algo así como
La Razón, pero con lectores.
Uno de los estereotipos más difundidos por los medios no
estadounidenses es que Trump se ha ganado el
corazón de los llamados "hillbillies",
esos americanos blancos de clase media
baja que viven en la zona central del
país. ¿Pero esto del todo cierto? ¿Se
puede caricaturizar al votante medio de
Donald Trump como una especie de Cletus Spuckler?
"-Cachis, Cletus, ¿por qué has aparcado al lado
de mis viejos?
- Ya lo sabes, porque también son
lo míos".
Realmente las encuestas post
electorales reflejan que le han votado un 63% de los hombres blancos, ¡el
doble que los que han votado a Hillary Clinton! Y
eso incluye a gente que estudia en la
universidad y que tienen trabajos
cualificados.
Lo mismo ocurre con las mujeres, el 53% de las mujeres blancas han
votado a Trump. En realidad los únicos
segmentos donde el oponente de Trump,
Hillary Clinton, ha conseguido ganar han
sido las minorías raciales. Y aún así
ha habido una gran sorpresa:
los hispanos. Sí, la mayoría han votado a Hillary, pero no tanto como se esperaba.
Y es que estos han dado mayor apoyo a
Trump que a Romney en las pasadas elecciones
de 2012.
La llave que tenían los hispanos en
estados como Florida ha acabado girando
a favor de Trump.
Esto puede explicarse en que muchos de
ellos, ciudadanos legales con derecho a
voto, pueden ver a los que están en
situación irregular como una
competencia laboral de la que Trump puede librarles. Personalmente más allá de
ideologías,
creo que es difícil de justificar que un
hispano decir a votar a Trump y acabé
por darle las llaves de la Casa Blanca.
"Yo sé que hay cosas que dice que no son
ciertas, pero lo que dice me gusta".
Así cuando en las elecciones de 2012 todos
los analistas coincidían en que es
imposible ganar unas elecciones sin el
apoyo del voto hispano y el
afroamericano, Trump ha demostrado que sólo es
suficiente con llegar a parte de él.
Otro punto crucial a favor de Trump ha sido su
mensaje anti globalización, que ha
calado especialmente en la zona de lo
que se conoce como "rust belt" o cinturón
industrial. De hecho, Hillary ha perdido en
estados como Michigan, Wisconsin o
Pennsylvania. Tres estados que los
demócratas no perdían desde 1992. Son
zonas que se han visto afectadas por la
no adaptación de su industria a la
competencia internacional y que han
visto en el discurso proteccionista
de Trump un posible futuro de esperanza.
Pero para explicar la victoria de Trump,
también debemos tener en cuenta la
desmovilización masiva del electorado
demócrata en estas elecciones.
¿Qué ha hecho mal la campaña de Hillary Clinton?
Wikileaks filtró una serie de emails
enviados por John Podesta,
el jefe de gabinete de Hillary Clinton,
en estos emails podestá señalaba la
importancia de mostrar a Trump como un
extremista.
"Todo lo que tenía que hacer
el equipo de campaña de Clinton era
dirigir a los medios tradicionales para
que cubrieran y atacaran a Donald
Trump ya que era la estrella de las
primarias republicanas".
Esta estrategia no ha servido más que
para incrementar las apariciones
públicas de Trump,
de hecho si buscáis en Google Trends
veréis que el interés suscitado entre
el público por Trump ha sido
considerablemente mayor que el despertado
por Hillary. Sencillamente el candidato
republicano ha dominado la campaña, en
todo momento se ha hablado sus
propuestas, los demócratas sólo se han
dedicado a reaccionar y es que a
diferencia de Hillary Clinton, de cuyo
eslogan nadie se acuerda,
Donald Trump ha conseguido que todos
tuviéramos en nuestra cabeza sus
mensajes: "hacer América grande de nuevo",
"identificar a Hillary con el fraude, la
mentira", "conseguir visualizar en la cabeza
de todo el mundo los cambios que va a
llevar a cabo nada más llegar al
gobierno:
el muro, romper el NAFTA, enfrentarse a China, hacer más barcos de guerra...
En definitiva, Hillary ha optado por una campaña
tranquila y muy poco atractiva. Es
cierto que Hillary se centró en captar a
los millennials, los jóvenes, mediante
campañas digitales probablemente
tratando de convencer a los partidarios
de Sanders, pero se olvidó de centrarse
en aquellos más crecidos donde Trump ha
sembrado su éxito. Pese a ello los
reultados han estado muy pero que muy
ajustados, de hecho si miramos los votos
populares es decir el número de
personas que han votado a cada candidato
Hilary estaría por encima, sin
embargo el sistema americano de colegios
electorales hace que Trump sea el
vencedor final.
Y la pregunta es, ¿podemos aprender algo de la campaña de Donald Trump? ¿Vale
cualquier estrategia con tal de ganar
unas elecciones?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Si nos estás viendo pero
aún no te has suscrito al canal, hazlo aquí ahora mismo dando click a este botón.
Si te ha gustado este esoecial sobre las elecciones
americanas, dale a like para hacérnoslo saber.
¡Un saludo y hasta el próximo vídeo!